así
ya vimos cómo se comportan las curvas de
becilla geométricamente ahora veamos el
álgebra de ellas empezando con el
polígono de tres puntos como antes
construimos un punto cursando
interpolación lineal que es el promedio
ponderado en el segmento de la línea ave
algebraica mente cupo de expresarse como
q igual a 1 de x además de por ver a
continuación calculamos el punto r en el
segmento de la línea de c lo que
significa que r puede expresarse como 1
- depor b master por c finalmente
conectamos culleré y hacemos una última
interpolación lineal para obtener p el
punto de la curva p es igual a 1 - t por
q más de poner de esta última ecuación
parece que es de grado 1 en t pero las
primeras dos ecuaciones también dependen
de t entonces vamos a sustituir las
primeras dos ecuaciones en la tercera
para obtener esta expresión combinada
multiplicando y factor izando podemos
escribir de la siguiente forma p es
igual a 1 menos de al cuadrado por a más
2 t por uno menos t por b más te al
cuadrado por c todos estos términos al
cuadrado demuestran que en realidad es
una función polinomiales del segundo
grado interesante un polígono de tres
puntos nos lleva a una función polinomio
de segundo grado eso tiene sentido
porque hay dos etapas de interpolación
lineal en la primera etapa calculamos
culleré y en la segunda etapa calculamos
p ahora qué pasa con el grado si
empezamos con un polígono de cuatro
puntos lo pueden adivinar
en la primera etapa calculé tres puntos
usando interpolación lineal en la
segunda etapa calculé dos puntos y en la
tercera etapa solo calculé un punto como
tenemos tres etapas la curva resultante
será de tercer grado eso significa que
un polígono de cuatro puntos resulta en
una curva de tercer grado
puedes generalizar el algoritmo de de
kassel joe empezando con 56 o cualquier
número de puntos la regla es que si
empezamos con n puntos obtendrán una
función polinomio de grado n menos un
genial
y felicitaciones por terminar esta
lección si se sienten particularmente
intrépidos intenten hacer el siguiente
desafío extra